Film Courage: Adisa, you grew up in West Oakland,
California? Adisa, Filmmaker: Yes I grew up in
West Oakland. I grew up in the 70's (well I came
of age in the 70's) in West Oakland California my
mother lived there my father lived in Vallejo
California which is about 30 minute drive away
and they split up when I was about five years
old and but my father was always present in my
life he would come see us every weekend or pick
us up every weekend so i almost had two homes
growing up i'd be like living in vallejo on
the weekends and i'd be living with my mother
during the weekday and it was very supportive
and nurturing environment i have uh one brother
and two sisters did you go to marine world uh yeah
in vallejo you know about it oh yeah well when i
grew up in vallejo there was no marine world yeah
there wasn't one at that time it was just like uh
it was like just a back um woody area with a
pond you know it was dan minnie park is what
it was called right and so we would go there as
kids and we'd fish and we would play we had a
tree house there it was like great it was just
like this expansive land and then um when i got
to high school they built marine world and then
we'd wake up in the morning we'd hear dolphins
and we'd hear you know the seagulls and
all that stuff because i lived literally
um maybe about five minutes oh wow that close okay
yeah well you said you had supported parents even
though you were you were going back and forth
but you said that a lot of kids that you knew
growing up in west oakland their lives
weren't like that yeah yeah for a lot of kids
uh especially my like my friend my best friend
terry for a lot of years i never saw his father
and um so i just assumed you know i didn't
know where he was but his father was in prison
right and that was the reality for a lot of
kids growing up in west side oakland either
they were on drugs and i'm not say all of
them but i just wasn't present to a lot
of kids that had fathers in the home and uh
yeah for reasons that i mean we can get into
you know black men growing up in oakland
you know endangered species and all that but
uh yeah so but i had a father he was always
stable he was always in my life and then
sometimes my friends would envy that right and
what i saw my father do and i think i have that
trait now he would extend himself to those kids
sometimes he would give my friends allowances
right and sometimes if we were going somewhere
he would say hey ask such and such to come along
so he became sort of this father figure for
a lot of kids growing up in the neighborhood
and i say that my connection to that because
as i start to look at my own life growing up
and the work i'm doing in sierra leone the
soccer tournaments i have the relationship
i have with the children over there and the
child minors and just my relationship with
children in general i kind of see that
i think i got that from my father yeah
wow that's that's interesting that's interesting
that the kids that you felt that that even at such
a young age that they knew like i don't have a
father present and you do and yeah yeah and if i
was and you know there could be a little bit of
shame involved with that like terry didn't tell me
his father was in prison and then his father would
come out and we'd be playing and all of a sudden
you know it'd be like 12 and then i wouldn't
see his father for another four years
and then i wouldn't see him for another year and
then we would see him when we were in high school
and then we'd work out at the gym and each other's
this workout at the park and we'd be doing nothing
but the bars and we're doing a strong little
workout i said wow your father's really strong
you know he's engaged with doing this workout you
know um enough to me that he was in prison a lot
of that time and so he came out it was sort of a
you know he was making connection back with his
son and i was getting to meet him but my friend
never told me he was in prison you see yeah so uh
yeah i mean i could say more on that but uh i
guess and so in some senses growing up in west
oakland also i was my mother and father protected
me from a lot also like I just you know there was
this side there's this thing about West Oakland
where you could live here but then if you go
and you this is this was true up in harlem a
few years ago not now but you could live here
but then you go one block over and it's like
you know it's drug infested and it's crack and
there's this and that and so but my mother always
kept me and my father always kept me on this side
so i never veered i could never veer over
there you know and not because of fear of
them but i think it's just because they um they
just instilled in me some really strong values
growing up and they set a good example like
my father said a really good example of
you know what to be as a man and uh similarly
with my mother also right i remember when crack
was was kind of like becoming a thing oh yeah
and so i remember people would always ask for
like 10 like because a rock was around like 10 or
something there was always a story centered around
ten dollars oh yeah because i grew up in the bay
area too and it was the same thing you crossed one
part in it was much different and so i remember
this one girl had this elaborate story and i
wanted to believe her but because she said the
ten dollar part i was like you know what i i they
the kids at school had said oh that the rocks cost
one rock was ten dollars and see what you alluded
to now see that's when kids know too much too fast
it's like this generation right now with the media
you know back then you could be living in the
hood and yes you would be exposed to things
that you shouldn't really know about crack weed
prostitution you know because we were living right
off of san pablo san pablo wasn't that far so
you could see prostitutes you know uh sometimes
during the day um and so that's when the young
kids um you get to be tampering with their minds
and you're giving them too much information to
you they're losing their innocence if you will
and so i think my mother and father tried to
protect my innocence for as long as possible
but i saw kids a lot younger than me that
had lost their innocence a lot earlier
yeah poverty would do that to you too you know
quick then you start knowing like for me i never
knew where food came from or that we were ever
like didn't have money you know but when you're
poor you know you don't have money or somebody's
gonna have a conversation in the house around
you know we don't have this we have to get food
stamps or you know emt yeah right or or also to
how the parents of the other kids treat you um
if you if if you're aware enough and you can tell
well yeah i'm sorry you can't come to the birthday
party yeah or there may not be a birthday party
yeah right yeah there may not be a birthday
party you know so yeah i guess so living in
that environment and being i guess growing up
at a level of i don't know what that i'm using
the word empathy now because it just it made
me having what i had and it just made me more
appreciative and it made me more just really
sensitive about who other people were i was
always the kid wanting to help somebody out i
was always the kid wanting to go the extra mile
to make sure somebody's feelings weren't hurt
and that was me that was me and my family too so
if spike lee didn't make she's got to have it
would you be a filmmaker today wow wow for you to
ask that question that is so poignant um because
it's likely that i wouldn't it is very likely
that i wouldn't i knew that uh i wanted to help
people i knew i wanted a career that was going to
service my community it was going to
be around possibly around black men
you know and uh and what that looked like i
was all you know rights of passage programs
or whatever but uh the film thing didn't become a
reality for me until i saw spike lee's early work
and i think it has a lot to do with modeling you
know um and we don't have a lot of you know it's
like whether it's women men uh black men that is
you you know there's something to be said about
representation and modeling and at the time
spike lee came around there wasn't a lot of
black filmmakers i mean that you knew about i
mean it was gordon parks he had done some work
uh the you know the shaft but i mean there weren't
and it was michael schultz you know he did coulee
high and but these aren't films that like i would
i was really i loved the films but i didn't know
particularly if they were a black man but it was
something about spike lee in his signature work
when he was doing uh she's got to have it he was
doing you know do the right thing and it was just
so pronounced and so much of a signature around
black culture that i was like this is what i want
to do so to answer your question which is a really
good question i don't know if i would have been a
filmmaker maybe i think i owe my career to spike
lee i don't know if i'd have been laying down that
path i don't yeah so it's really powerful i mean
he had a profound effect on me in terms of that
so you saw the film and then you decided to
go to college at nyu tisch yeah yeah well i
saw well i was going back east i was first
i was going to university of massachusetts
and then uh i saw i had heard about him making
a movie and then i saw the movie in new york
on my way to you know i was going to umass
amherst i drove cross country with a friend
and i was just blown away and so going into going
into umass amherst which is my junior year i set
the intention i want to be a filmmaker so i was
gonna do whatever i had to do to be a filmmaker so
i started taking film classes i started studying
film i started making films like on film like 16
millimeter boleks and uh crank cameras and uh and
then uh i had decided i was going to apply nyu
and i made a student film that got uh i
got a lot of awards at umass where i was
and um and i applied to nyu because despite me
with nyu and so that was sort of my my pulse and
my geiger my he was sort of my north star if you
will you know so i and i was reading all the books
that he had written at that time and so i applied
to nyu and i got in did you ever get to meet him
i did i met him first year yeah i met him the
first year because he came to the he uh there
was a woman named lisa jones who had written his
books right she was his uh yeah she was his his
collaborator on a lot of his film books and she
was at nyu and she was a few years ahead of me and
she said spike's gonna and i heard when i got this
fight like to meet with the black students right
he likes to meet with him you know the first year
and so he invited us all to 40 acres in a meal his
production company and i was like just you know i
mean i'm star struck because he was my idol he is
my idol he was my hero and i just shook his hand
and uh yeah it's just you know what did he say
um he didn't say much you know he was just
i mean spike was he was a presence more than
anything else because he was really back then
he was soft-spoken and he let his work speak
you know that was his thing and so for a
long time i was like wow how's this guy
doing this i mean because then the business
you got to be aggressive you got to be strong
but spike is very disciplined he's very focused
you know you read his books he would get up at
6 a.m in the morning write him right he had a
certain quote he had to write on a screenplay
and for you know for the first
like six seven years he would do
a movie every year it would come out and that
was his process you'd wake up 6am in the morning
you know write and they need to go about doing
this thing but so he's a very disciplined
individual and yeah but i was just like you know
well i was floored yeah it was lord he was my hero
at what point did you know you wanted to be
a filmmaker i think immediately after i saw
do the right thing yeah that was like pivotal for
me and just creatively the way he put it together
and i didn't just want to be a filmmaker i want
to be a black filmmaker i mean so that's the
distinction i wanted to make like i was aware of
other filmmakers out there but i was strongly um
concerned about like representation of black
people and you know what what that would mean
for for us as a collective in terms of us needing
filmmakers to tell our stories and so that became
a very important thing for me um so yeah so i kind
of um i embrace that i embraced that and they used
to have conversations back then too you're a
filmmaker you're black filmmaker filmmaker black
i mean we had a whole conversation at nyu where
people come in and actually say oh i'm not a black
actor i'm just an actor i get that i do get that
so yes i'm a filmmaker i'm a diesel v filmmaker
and so i don't want to be marginalized or i
don't want to be you know segregated over here
to this other classification but within the
larger context of being a filmmaker i'm also
an african-american it's like being a woman
filmmaker right yes you're a filmmaker we get
that but within the specifics of that you're also
a woman making movies right and the reason i think
you make those kind of distinctions is because
of just the racism in society right and how they
or the racism and the sexism and all that and how
they regulate regulated us to a certain area so i
but i took a lot of pride in it you know i take
a lot of pride in it and uh even today you know
i want to be a role model for kids too and uh so
yeah i'm a filmmaker i'm a black filmmaker i'm uh
yeah i'm a filmmaker who tells message stories
message films yeah well that's funny because
you must be reading my mind cause i was
gonna go to the message part and that is
did you see your parents uh be about a cause or
especially growing up in the bay area i know it's
very cause driven up there got the you know whole
influence from haight ashbury so did you see that
in them growing up there what was interesting
about my generation is that even though my mother
was a black panther i was very active in that
movement and my father had come from the south
where clearly um and my father my father had me
at a later age right and so he was born like 1921.
okay so he was coming from the south clearly went
through racism segregation he had been called boy
you know uh you know he was he was coming of age
where there wasn't a lot of opportunities for
blacks so he he ended up being a welder he was
a tradesman you know he became a welder and he
came out to california became a welder so you knew
he was very well aware of that and when he would
drive us home his home to see his grandmother
in the south in alabama during the summer's time
we would drive my father used to have a gun in the
car a gun and it was on the side of the door right
and so i'm like okay that's that's already
like why are we driving with a gun and
then when a white cop would pull us over and
this happened and invariably it would happen
right he would get out my father was very
slow in his motions he would get out very slow
he would say yes officer no officer yes officer
was i speeding officer okay i was speeding officer
okay like to see your license yes officer you
could show you my life he was very like overly um
congenial right and then he would get out but
now in retrospect you know he was really probably
concerned about the safety of his children
and we were in arkansas or we were in texas
and where you know something could happen right
and so and because of his background coming from
the south which he knew all too well um you know
this is how he behaved in the presence of you know
of law enforcement if you will and so but i
say all that to say that so when i came of age
i think my father didn't tell me much about that
at all like he didn't really and i know my mother
didn't tell me about the 60s and the black panther
movement either it was later when i started going
into college and i saw a book laying around it was
huge newton's book blood in my eye and i was like
mom what is this no it was george um george
jackson's blood in my eye and i was like mom
what is this you know or hugh p newton's book
and he had signed and autographed it for her
and then she would say oh yeah this is blah blah
and but they tried to protect me from that they
did and my father tried to protect me from all
that atrocities you seen that with a lot of i
think my generation that came of age was like they
just didn't tell us about it as if you know they
were trying to protect us so that we could create
our own futures and they didn't want to harm us
because that was a very harmful period in our
history yeah so i didn't grow up knowing much
about it wasn't until later that i would
start to investigate it would you see your
mom going to meetings protesting no no beyond
that at that point it was beyond that and so
yeah i didn't see that and she didn't talk about
it and my father didn't talk about the south
and they never talked about it it was only
later when i went to college that i would read
up on it and or when i read the autobiography
malcolm x i remember and i was i'm so curious
i said dad blah blah you know about mountains
yeah i knew about him he was in the north right
but then he wouldn't say much about him you know
and he just wouldn't he wouldn't say much about
him my mother was the same way they didn't talk
about it like what about cointelpro like did they
did they and my mother knew about cointelpro and
all that stuff but she didn't talk about because
for them i think it was it was let's not it wasn't
about passing on that information because uh
it's weird now to think about it because so
we grew up in sort of not a utopia but it's
like we didn't know about all that that becomes
this big schism between us and i think in the
jewish community you don't necessarily always
see that because they teach they keep teaching
you know the generations the holocaust becomes
a constant reminder and you know you start going
through bar mitzvah and you know whether it's the
rights of passage programs they do and it's like
here here's your information here's your
history whereas with us as african-americans
sometimes it's like um we don't some of us i don't
say all of us but that generational information is
not passed down and so and i think because of the
60s and turbulence of that and what was happening
in the south my mother in them just didn't want
to pass it on and my friends didn't know about it
either you know growing up in oakland but i mean
would it probably be no different than basketball
players now and you talk talking about uh you
know not lou alcindor not kareem but probably like
eldridge baylor and they're like well who's that
you know they may not have that direct connection
to who he is in terms of history but it's
then during that time that i began to see
the connections to history and why we must know
our history and how we empower ourselves through
our history yeah and how that history can also
determine your future right and so that's when
i started to make that connection with spike
lee just to bring that back home in terms of
who he was as a filmmaker and then connecting
that to you know how we didn't have images
as black people or even so even the images that
we did have whether it was coffee brown or some
of the exploitation movies we didn't direct we did
not direct them so it's like oh okay so that's uh
i need to i need to change that your first short
film was in 1994 yeah it was called notre dame key
and i collaborated on that was avery williams and
it was more like a mini feature it was more like
uh i mean we were like because and i say
that because avery i love him dearly he's
in uh atlanta right now he's teaching at morehouse
but he wrote that script and he brought it to me
uh to direct and i was like well you know
we're going to do this through the school
and we sort of did it through the school but we
sort of didn't do the school we kind of broke all
the rules right we used the school's equipment
um but we ended up uh we we so we started the
film process there but then um because of my
earlier work i had gotten the attention of
disney hollywood pictures and they started this
discretionary fund program and so they decided to
give us forty thousand dollars to make that movie
it was a period films period film set in harlem
1947. and we had keith david in it we had harry
linux in it you know both big actors right now and
so we were just young kids just i mean just
like fresh behind the ears you know 21 22.
you know not really knowing a whole lot what
we're doing figuring it out as we go but just
kept keeping it very professional and um and that
film went on to win a lot of awards and get me a
lot of attention got both of us a lot of attention
wow and forty thousand and ninety four yes
yeah that's a lot that's a lot so it's 2019 now
and you are just releasing your first feature film
yeah yeah um i think the ad is about the whole
old adage about you know what's holding you back
you it probably stands true and i think for
a lot of years i resisted um writing right
i became a better writer over the years but when
i first started out i didn't really particularly
write as much and i think that the filmmakers
that are really prolific or the ones that really
uh can get there faster they generate their own
material right and they write so it goes hand in
hand they write and they direct they write near
it so if you don't write you're either having
defined material or work with other writers
right and so i didn't write for a lot of years
and so when we look at the gap between when i
graduated film school when i came out with my
first feature a lot of it is because um i was
learning how to write in that period of time
yeah i was learning how to write were you
reading screenplay books i was reading
screenplay books but then life happens yeah
you know and so i came out here uh early 2000
um high hopes of directing but it just didn't
happen for me right away it didn't happen i had
to get a job and so then i started looking
at what what are my options and then uh
i had always done sound in school i was
pretty good at doing sound as a production
sound person in school so then i started doing
sound out in l.a on commercials and videos and
so then what was it that made you want to
do a feature film like why were you ready
what is it two years ago yeah yeah well time
was getting away from me you know and i i had
figured that was my dream you know i didn't want
to get away from my dream of being a director
and so i just hankered down and i did whatever
it took i just that was my mantra i just decided
i'm going to do whatever it takes and i'm going
to confront myself at every corner and so look
at my weaknesses and i make my weaknesses into
strengths and so then i just started to write
and write and write and uh and then then i
hooked up with another collaborator another uh
writer stephen pearson stephen palmer peterson and
he wrote skin in the game and um yeah so were you
almost uh emulating spike lee getting up at six i
was getting up at six literally i mean it's like
even right now you know like the cost you know it
takes a lot to be a filmmaker and i think those
that make it other probably it's it's more it's
more determination and persistence versus talent
a lot of times i mean talent hand in hand you
know you know you take that for granted but you
want to be talented at it but i think it's it's
really about persistence and determination and
how much you're willing to sacrifice in some cases
um yeah because in some cases there it you know
you've got you may not be eating you know you
may be eating top ramen or you may be taking
some least attractive jobs because
it allows you more time to write
right and i think this when i made that
decision and you're not leaning on other people
in other words your the responsibility for your
life and becoming a filmmaker is yours it doesn't
belong to your wife so your partners or your
boyfriends or your mothers or your fathers
so it's not about them sponsoring you or giving
you a cushion or saying okay you know what you go
ahead and write here's i'm gonna pay your rent for
the next couple months so it's it was about taking
complete responsibility for for my dream and what
i wanted to make happen and what that looked like
and so yeah so if it met working all day
and writing all night then that's what i did
was it about what 10 years ago you had something
that happened that your heart stopped through
different times oh you've done your research uh
i went 10 years ago i went to sierra leone with
isaiah washington on a documentary film shoot and
on that shoot that shoot literally would change
my life uh not only did i get exposed to sierra
leone and um the conditions over there because
they had just undergone a civil war and isaiah
was looking up his roots and i was part of the
documentary team i had a great experience but
when i came back i had a near-death experience
because i had cotton virus over there called
the hantavirus and when i got back to l.a
i mean i was just i was just fatally ill and i
had to be rushed to the hospital i was in the icu
and my heart stopped beating three times i had
uh multiple organ failure and i was in really
bad shape and the doctors didn't think i was gonna
make it nobody thought i was gonna make it so my
mother at that time flew up here and uh people
were just praying i mean i was just in critical
condition and but miraculously i made it through
yeah i made it through did they know what it was
they didn't at the time they didn't and uh it
was a good thing that i was at what they called
uh was it danny freeman more hospital and they
were like oh thank god you didn't go to like cedar
cyanide because the daniel freeman hospital they
could bring in other technicians from everywhere
like hey brian people from ucla they could
bring in doctors from usc to uh to help on
my case right whereas i've been seaters they have
like clear rules about cedars-side doctors working
there and you can't bring others in but because
i was at daniel freeman hospital they were able
to bring another doctor so nobody knew what i had
all i knew was i had multiple organ failure and my
body was shutting down and this one particular
doctor stayed with me and he had to restart my
heart three times in the middle of the night and
so yeah i know it looked like i was on my deathbed
it looked like i was on my day and actually i
thought i was on my deathbed too the only thing
kept me going was the fact that because i one
morning at one point i remember myself making um
sort of this uh resolve that like you know what
i'm gonna if i'm gonna die my last moments were
in africa my last moments were playing with
children my last moments were with like you know
um having fun and sharing of my gifts with
everybody because that's where that's what
i was doing after giving out soccer balls
and i made some serious relate some nice
relationships over there so i said you
know what if i gotta go then so be it
i had made it i had made peace with it you
know and uh but it was another plan for me
it was another plan i'm here and how long were
you in the hospital i was there for about uh i
was probably there for about seven to eight weeks
total but for like three weeks i was sedated
and i was under heavy sedation as the doctors
treated me and put me on dialysis and we just
you know trying everything to fix me trying
everything to make me better but nothing worked
and they didn't know so they said they just had
to let it run its course and just let me be you
know just let me be sort of get let my body fight
it and uh so yeah so then when you returned home
did you have any kind of like awakening where like
okay now because i've been to this point where
most people haven't been there or they end up oh
yeah oh yeah things are going to be different now
oh yeah yeah yeah much so that what happened was
when i got back and i got well i shocked everybody
because i told my mother when to go back to africa
and she was like oh no you can't go back to africa
oh no you're not going to do that to me again my
mother's beside herself my father uh everybody
tripped out i mean they were like no you can't go
back because i got an opportunity to go back with
um was it regina king yeah regina king the actress
had invited me to go back and work with her on her
documentary and so they were like no you can't
go back you can't go away especially we went back
to sierra leone in the same place and so people
were freaking out like freaking out and uh but i
was resolved i was like you know what i'm better i
can do this and i wanted to do this i wanted to be
there was some things that had happened to me by
being sick you know like i was having revelations
around my life and what i wanted to do with
my life and and how i wanted to show up and so
yeah and going back to africa was part of
it so even in your like i mean when you were
conscious but laying in this bed or whatever
you knew like yeah yeah if i got better i knew
i wanted to go back and i did go back and
um and not only did i go back i started the
foundation of an azer foundation not only did
i go back i had a soccer tournament we would do
every year and we would put kids through uh um
school we had foundation for that i mean i was
like i was working to get the kids out of the
diamond mines i was very active still am mm-hmm
and did you finish that documentary about
the i did yeah in the document and then
then i shot a documentary on it me going back
so the documentary captures me going back
hosting the soccer tournament giving the kids
uh uh money for school and giving a look at
what the kids were doing in the diamond mines
yeah and these are miners though these are young
miners like seven years old 14 muhammad and
musa yeah i mean they're older now but yeah
yeah and so that was a really powerful thing
for me and that actually started the ball
rolling with my film career again because once
i did that documentary i was just hungry and
wanted to do a feature right so then what i did
was uh i wrote a feature based on my experience
or rebirth experience about going to africa and
this trauma that i was experiencing so it was
sort of a true life story although i substituted
myself for a football player i made a little bit
more commercial and we spent i spent a lot of
years trying to get that going and i couldn't
get it going and then after a number of years
i just thought you know i got it i got to work
on it because i couldn't raise the financing so i
said let me work on a project that i can do that's
doable something that um is uh it's not going
to cost a lot of money and i just happened to
be with oakland at the time and then my sister
was talking about uh how she wouldn't let her
young daughter ride the bus i said why don't you
let your daughter ride the bus and why are you
driving around everywhere because that wasn't
my experience growing up and she said with the
gorilla pimps up here and just recently there was
a gorilla pimp that snatched a girl off the bus
and put her into prostitution i was like whoa
really and so that stuck with me that stuck
with me and in the midst of that i'm looking
for my next subject matter in terms of my film
then i came back up to oh came back up to la and
on the newscast that the exact same week it was
talking about a young girl who was prostituting
herself on long beach boulevard and i was like
oh wow so i just couldn't ignore those two
sort of circumstances or two instances of
prostitution and trafficking that came up and at
the time i didn't know it was called trafficking i
was just like prostitution prostitution it wasn't
until i would read it later that i would say oh
they're the one in the same prostitution
trafficking these girls don't want to do it
some of them are being manipulated coerced
you know and that's how and i just started
to research it heavily and then um started
to think about what a film could look like
i'm just curious do people notice that you
had changed in that you had gone through
where you you faced death and then when they
saw you again after maybe a year later they
noticed your personality was different or
and that you had a new sort of purpose or
um i think the light had turned on more i'm not
gonna say it was completely different i mean i was
like i was already like a very positive optimistic
person wanting to do things but i was probably
stopping myself like the tournament in africa and
working with the kids i never thought i could do
that you know like there was something about
the way i was living life that i felt like um
that was larger than what i could do
right and so i started to so yes to
answer your question once i got better i
started to test the boundaries more like
around greatness enlargeness and saying that
i can do it i can do that why not right and so
yeah in that way and then having to experience
death also i mean it just gives you this sense of
i'm not saying immortality but you to experience
and be that close to death and to know that it
can be snapped away from you that at an instant
it kind of sharpened my focus about living life
in the present moment to moment and
doing as much as i can in that moment
and that was in 2009 yeah so do you notice that a
trajectory of what you've done since you like if
you saw like a timeline yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
from the documentary to the the trafficking movie
the one skin in the game we're going to talk about
shortly yeah yeah and then you know but along that
we just have to realize that it just takes a
lot to make it in film i mean it's not like
maybe talking overnight successes 18 years
you know somebody said oh yeah you made it man
you're over and it's been working at it for 12
years 13 years you know some cases 20 years um
you know you never see a young morgan freeman on
the screen i mean like can you imagine a young
what would a young morgan freeman look like
you know you've seen him in his 40 you know
you see me when he did glory and all that and
he's already older he's like i'm just like in
his 40s but what does a younger one look like you
know it's a lecture company you know but so i so i
say that to say that you know it was happening
for me but nothing happens overnight and so it
was just a lot of hard work and um and a lot of
dedication a lot of time did you think before that
it was possible to be this over like when you were
leaving tish did you think you know what you know
i i cause i think people don't realize sometimes
how how long it takes to get something yeah i no
i mean if you told me when i graduated that it
was gonna take uh 15 years to do a feature i've
been like no i've been like you're kidding you
know you're out of your mind i would be more like
that right and so no i mean i thought it was
gonna happen right away and then i got uh you
know i got hit in the face with reality filmmaking
what it really takes and um and not only that but
sometimes it just takes a lot of luck it takes a
lot of being in the right place at the right time
so and sometimes it just takes what it takes
sometimes it just it took me like if i had to
say would i want to do any of it over no because
you know if i had made it right out of film school
i probably would have gone to sierra leone right
i wouldn't have been gone i wouldn't have been a
sound man so i wouldn't have gone over there with
isaiah washington i uh i wouldn't have um started
a foundation so my life probably would have been
on another trajectory so i don't have any regrets
it happened the way it happened i embraced that
yeah and and um to answer your question about just
being stronger yeah so the experience made
me stronger and it challenged me to be better
with skin in the game what made that project
different from the other movies that you had
gotten off the ground or been a part of yeah skin
in the game was probably one of the hardest films
i had to make up to this point because emotionally
i had to take myself emotionally and in the
writing i had to take myself to a really dark
place right trafficking is a dark dark world
and so it was probably it probably would
have been my first choice but i was
somehow compelled i was just compelled to tell the
story after meeting the women talking to survivors
i just got deeper and deeper and i just
said this is something i have to do
but um yeah but i think i probably resisted it
at first only because of the the you know the
subject matter and the darkness of it but then
at some point i just uh i couldn't avoid it as
a filmmaker and as a human being i mean i was just
as a human being i felt like i needed to tell the
story i feel like the voice of these women needed
to be told yeah and were some of the women that
i mean on set were they survivors of this yeah oh
yeah we had one in particular her name was jayla
baxter uh there's another woman named deleta
miller both survivors uh both uh had been
trafficked at some point both um were prostitutes
escorts you know and then they were on the other
side of it now they were now rescuing girls right
and they were in a leadership position so they
gave us a lot of counsel and i mean i leaned
on them heavily in the research of the movie
well terms you know the subject matter you know
i mean something jayla would always say was
you know a young boy doesn't grow up thinking he
wants to be a pimp you know so remember that in
terms of empathy to everybody involved right and
so you know pimps have been grown too you know a
lot of times what i've studied in the research not
to give them a pass but i've found that um if you
look at their backgrounds and the women sometimes
that are traffic they're equally the same you know
no father abusive father molestation right neglect
um not feeling loved yeah a lot of that stuff
right and so just empathy i mean she just really
jayla was just really strong and talking about
empathy and she was really strong on talking about
boys and girls being trafficked it was just girls
it was boys too so a lot of stuff i was hearing
for the first time like they were living it but
i was hearing it for the first time you know and
how did you meet them uh well at first it was
it was really hard to get into the community and
when i say the community it's like uh i was go to
meetings trafficking organization meetings but i
couldn't meet the girls i couldn't meet survivors
for obvious reasons you know because number one
uh i'm a filmmaker so they they're thinking oh
exploitation they could be thinking that you know
cash exploitation or what that could mean um and
then i was an outsider i didn't know anybody and
so then when i try to talk to some of the girls
it's hard too because a male talking to a young
survivor could also be a trigger for her you
know and when i say trigger that's like a woman um
who's been through a trauma when experience right
and then uh a male figure shows up and whether
you know my hair complexion whatever it could have
it could have been a trigger for her you know
me interviewing her talking to her so they want
to avoid that giving these women triggers you
know what i mean uh like uh there was one woman
i interviewed who said that she's a survivor and
a leader and she you know had been through a lot
but she said that if her pimp came in the room
right now and said let's go and she'd been out
of life like say 10 years but she said if her
pimp came in the room right now said let's go
she said she would get up and walk out with him
yeah so this living trauma that these go through
that these women go through was real and so i had
to you know the level of sensitivity around that
and having to having to live and breathe the
story for a long time before i was able to
put it on paper and you wrote the film
no i actually i came up with the story
and i kind of yeah i kind of did the outline and
the treatment but then steve peterson came on and
he wrote the script how did you meet steve i met
steve because i was working on um the first film
um it was called diamonds in the rough this was
the one going back to africa and uh steve had
did give he did some work on that script and
i met him through another producer tom shell
and then when we took the script uh skinning the
game to howard who eventually produced it howard
bear show we can't do films we went through a
whole nother development process yeah because i
had originally wrote the script like um i don't
know if you remember the movie traffic with
michael douglas but it was it was yeah it was what
happened when that movie had multiple story lines
like it was him it was this was this and so that's
how i envisioned telling the story of these girls
like i had one being abducted i had one was had a
romeo pimp who had groomed her into the life i had
another woman that was uh a seasoned prostitute
in there so it was like these multiple story lines
intersecting right but then when i took it to
howard bearish and howard was very seasoned at
making movies especially independent movies
and how would it work with ava duvenay and
he worked with her on um middle of nowhere and
her first film i will follow and he had you know
he had films go to sundance so he was like the
seasoned shepherd producer and so when i took
him the story he was like i like it and he wanted
to get involved because he he himself had been
touched by trafficking also and so and he was also
coming into this new awareness of what this was
because it was everywhere and it was all around
us and i started to share the story with him and
uh the more i shared the more he got enthused and
wanted to get behind the film uh but he thought
it was just too large like it was too much going
on it was too many different stories so his first
suggestion was you got to streamline you got
to streamline it and you know tell a singular
story right and this was for not just it was for
budgetary reasons it was for festival reasons
you know uh yeah and it was for good filmmaking
reasons at that at that particular point too so
it's just that it's not all over the place and
we didn't have the budget to really support that
and so i went back to the woodshed and then that's
when i um i leaned heavily on uh jayla and jayla
i met jayla she's a trafficking or survivor and a
leader and she's she this woman is she's amazing
an amazing woman and she's rescued over 5000 girls
five thousand five hundred boys and girls within
an eighteen year period and i found her i don't
know by chance fate i don't know you call it but
she was in watts teaching in her grandmother's
bait or one of her relatives basement church about
how gangs are trafficking young girls and i saw
the flyer how gangs are trafficking young girls
learn about this and find out how to prevent it so
i went and uh wow she blew my way she blew me away
and then i met with her afterward and we
talked and uh and then she became very integral
and it's sort of the development of the
way the story was being unfolded now
and she came on board as a consultant and uh um
yeah as a consultant for us because donald the
story is about a mother and a daughter and then
yeah getting a formula yeah she and she was always
in it the mother and daughter was always in it
but um i it wasn't about a woman former prostitute
rescuing her and that's what howard made the
input and said you got to streamline it and
then we realized that um to tell that particular
story i needed to know more about that woman
because i didn't know much about her you know the
prostitute now rescuing girls and that's when i i
started to research and talk to jayla a lot and
delete a miller was there ever a time you wanted
to give up filmmaking wow you know what i have to
be in terms of me wanting to give up filmmaking
i don't think there's ever been a time i wanted
to give up honestly i mean there's always been
there's been hard times i mean there's been times
where i've uh there was one time when i first
moved to la and i literally lived in six different
places in seven no i lived in eight different
places in six months and there was one time when
my friend moved i moved with him because i was
just couch surfing i would be here and i'd be here
so and then there was a time i lived out of my car
right literally i was just living out of my car
and so i've had some really hard times but i've
never wanted to give up never in terms of and
maybe it's because i just went too far down
that road and i was like oh there's nothing else
i want to do but um the vision of being a director
and a filmmaker has always been there you know
despite you know circumstances yeah but but i've
had you know looked out of my car i lived out of a
sound stage um yeah i've i've yeah paid the price
and not that everybody has to do that right um
but when you're you know when you have a dream
and you're committed you know and that's
and it's something that you believe in
wholeheartedly then you'll do whatever it takes
you'll do whatever it takes to make it happen
so you were living out of your car and were you
still being creative or at least attempting to be
creative no it was hard to answer your question
living out of my car and being creative it was
hard and uh no i wasn't i was still writing but
it was hard and at some point um i had to just
find a job and that's when i started to do the
sound thing more seriously you know just to keep
a roof over my head you know people don't realize
how hard it is to be a filmmaker in la but when
you first get here you don't know anybody it's
tough and so i had to get out of survival mode
right i had to get to a place where now i have
money coming in i'm paying the rent i'm eating
i don't have to call home and ask my mother for
money for you know for rent i had to so so being
in survival mode is a really hard place to be
and uh but la is not it's not an easy place to
break in it's just not you know you come out here
a lot of people doing what you want to do um more
some more committed than others uh relationships
take precedent a lot of time but when you first
get there who do you know right you're building
your foundation you're building your network
and so and that takes time it takes a lot of
time my advice is sometimes when people first
get out here i'm like you know sometimes before
you even get here if you're wherever you are
you know idaho or you know or oakland california
if you will but you know to get a body of work
write scripts have four or five scripts you
know or two three or three scripts don't just
come out here one script have two or three
scripts then come out here right then that
way you you're gonna be struggling you're gonna
be living but you've got a body of work now you
can kind of go out and shop that uh but but to do
that while you're out here it can be really tough
especially when you're struggling so once you
got this stable job and you got an apartment or
your roommate or whatever yeah then did you did
it happen gradually or did you feel like okay
now now that i have something coming in every
two weeks or whatever this paycheck i can start
writing and whatever yeah yeah well i gotta tell
you i had i had to get out of the out of the place
of i would meet people and they would give me hope
like i would get my script to somebody and someone
like oh i can do what i can do but then i had
to realize that a lot of people in l.a just talk
right and so um and i would call home mom i meant
such and such or or uh you know girlfriend if i
had it at the time oh i guess got the script so
i just had to get out of that place right and
so now having done it for a lot of years now um i
have ex i don't i take the expectation off of it
like i have hopes that um everything is going to
happen but i take the expectation like meaning i'm
going to give this person a script they're going
to green light it we're going to make it and it's
going to be done because that doesn't happen a lot
of times right and if you always set yourself up
for that like oh it's going to happen then you're
living in a constant state of disappointment so
i think the best thing to do is just sort of give
it to somebody and release give it to somebody you
have high hopes but don't be too attached to it or
the expectation right because you may set yourself
up for disappointment and um and a lot of people
i know a lot of writers i know go through a lot
of depression you know i don't want to come
out of the house i want to talk to people
and so i'm not i'm not that kind of person um but
yeah i've just learned to sort of just release
i mean put the effort you know in the case of
howard when i gave him the script and we started
to talk about it i mean it was a year later i mean
we developed that thing for a whole year like so
it didn't just happen like i gave it to him piqued
his interest he liked it but he wanted to develop
it right and he developed it me not even knowing
he was gonna make it i mean it was never a promise
or him saying oh yeah you know if we get to this
place i'm gonna give you the money or i'm gonna
finance it it was just it was a cordial it was a
great relationship the script was becoming better
so i didn't mind the relationship because he
would give us notes and the script would be better
so at the end of that process whether he was
going to make it or not i was going to have a
better script so i was like there's a win-win for
me and then uh but then at the end of that year
he felt really good about the script and where
it was at in terms of place and he said let's go
ahead and make it i think we can make it in uh you
know i think it was at that time it was maybe in
august and he said we can make it in november and
he had another film he was going to do before mine
and then he pulled the trigger on it yeah i always
think it's like a kiss of death when somebody
says especially to a young person i want to help
you yeah and i don't mean to sound negative but
you really do have to have your guard up
especially those those words yeah yeah listen i've
met with uh since i've directed that film skin
in the game i've met with some big tv directors
right i won't even name the names and uh but i
don't go in there thinking oh they're gonna help
me they're gonna put me on you know that's that's
what some people young people like that term being
put on somebody's gonna grab you you're gonna
have some kind of wizard of oz or boom and now
you're on and i just it doesn't happen like that
a lot of times and then you have to ask what's
it in for that other person sure you know like
i generously give myself to other people now i
want i want to help other people you know but i
know it's because it's just part of who i am but
some people aren't built like that some people you
know i mean they may give you one word of advice
and that's it don't ask me for nothing else right
and so and some people will go beyond that but
so i i've just learned to kind of um just take
what people can give me you know take and to
the point about meeting with these directors i
don't expect anything from them hey listen if the
guys can tell me what helped them what worked
for them sometimes that's good enough for me
yeah yeah i know there was another person that was
upset because they felt that the peers around them
had or the people around them that were sort of
peers had made it and that person hadn't yeah
and they're upset they said they won't help me
yeah but at some point i i have to think that
someone can't risk their reputation and just
trying to pull up their friends too well i've
had that happen too and my conversation around
that especially when it comes down to uh well in
general it's a tough thing to do because um well
let me back up i'm gonna say what i wanted to say
so uh when it comes down to black filmmakers and
women women filmmakers i admire what abe was doing
you know like he was hiring women filmmakers to
direct for the first time on her show queen sugar
right and by giving them a shot and some of these
women have done shorts but most of them have done
independent features but nobody looks at them
right so then when they take meetings they're
saying at the meetings tv meetings that is i want
to direct tv they're like well have you ever done
tv what becomes a catch-22 well how am i going to
do tv if i've never done it and how are you going
to give me a shot if i've never done it but yet
they've done these feature films right but ava is
eliminating all that she's giving women a shot to
direct qualified women now women that have proven
themselves you know and but we can more of us can
benefit from that right like especially for me
when you're talking about like i don't use
minorities but when you're talking about like
people that don't traditionally have a shot and
that have been kept out of the mainstream right
so then i think you have to set up not just lip
service programs but work with these people and
if they qualify to get them in sort of creating
this new pool of filmmakers if you will is that
a lot of the filmmakers she's reaching out to
have independent films they've done shorts so
they've done something so they've qualified
themselves on a certain level right and now
she's giving him access to directv and now so when
they go back to producers in television and say
um and a lot of the directors by the way have
gone on sally richardson you know cheryl daniel
have gone on to do television beyond ava but
she's given them that start but these filmmakers
have all paid dues and i make i make that a
specific point because people don't want to pay
dues anymore they just want to be put on they want
to come out to la and they want somebody to just
like a fairy godmother to just come in and say
here or they want to write one script or they
want to write two scripts and say oh i'm ready
you know and it just takes more than that um
i've paid a lot of dues uh and i think that people
should pay dues you know and when i say pay dues
it's really about just uh getting better at
your craft right or doing you know sometimes
you have to be an assistant before you can be
a writer before you can be in the writer's room
right or sometimes you have to be uh you know
direct shorts before you can direct the feature
right so it's about paying those kind of dues um
in my case i don't even know if i look at it as
dues anymore it's it's more as just a necessary
stepping stone to get where you want to be like
i've paid dues but for me now
it's like climbing the mountain
now i'm here okay and now i got to get to here and
i'm grabbing here and so for me just because i've
done an independent film i still feel like
i'm paying dues like i've gone listen i've
come a long way and i want to applaud my efforts
and the people around me that have supported me
to do this feature film right but to do another
film at another budget point is going to require
another kind of paying dues so i haven't made
it by any stretch of the imagination right and
what is making it mean anyway you know so i mean i
mean i think we all set our own standard for what
success is and so i'd like to think that i'm
successful at this level in terms of having done
this feature film but there's other milestones
and other goals that i want to set for myself
can we go back to just what steps you took either
to meet howard barrish the producer or how did you
what was your like initial pitch to him
yeah howard bearish was an interesting um
milestone for me because prior to meeting howard
i had developed scripts and written scripts but
i was always in the minds remember i'm learning
about filmmaking but in i'm in the mindset i'm
gonna get into an independent i'm trying to raise
independent financing right and for me that looks
like my mother may be giving ten thousand dollars
if my mother had it or a friend giving five
thousand dollars just finding money like that or
and i was led down the wrong path so many times
talking to people in atlanta talking to a casting
director who knew somebody with money in atlanta
and they get excited about the project and say oh
they yeah they we want to get we want to get this
thing going we like it blah blah blah you don't
hear from them again right and that had happened
so many times like i mean the meeting the amount
of people i had talked to that weren't really
i'm gonna say i'm gonna use a qualifier here they
never produced a film before they never uh given
money to a film before so that becomes for any
filmmaker going out there to making a movie i mean
certainly you can work with people that have never
done it before and they're going to give money
but i think i just get it's just a better fit if
somebody's done it before like you take your film
or script to a production company that makes it
you know or you take it to another company that
makes movies like you know they have a history
of that right versus um okay let me you know
take it to this person let's take it to this
person i had done that for years i don't know
why but i was doing that for years and so and
i was always reaching dead ends okay and this
is before um gofundme and um and and all that
but uh so i had uh i had worked on the script
and i met with a camera guy friend of mine and
he had worked with howard he worked with him
on a few projects so he knew howard right and
the camera guy said uh he said yeah you know i
think i can get it to this guy uh howard
bearish you know he makes movies and uh
yeah because he he you know he did some stuff with
ava uh duva doof i mean i didn't even know who
avery duvenne was right he's like uh it's a friend
of mine right he's like uh he did some stuff with
ava ava duva i said duvenay he said yeah yeah
that's her that's her that's her i said really
so i got excited immediately because i was like
oh howard barry she said stuff for david doing
and i had already started up on ava right i knew
who ava was and eve at that time i think she did
did she sell what was she doing selma yeah she was
shooting selma and uh you see the in the middle of
shooting some more [ __ ] shot selma and so i was
like yeah yeah if you can make the introduction
please and so he made the introduction and howard
called me and uh we had well no i sent howard the
script first and then it took howard a while
to read it but you learn that in this business
too people are like like people are not pressed
to read your script you're not gonna give it to
them they're like oh yeah i want to read over the
weekend it just doesn't happen and so you learn to
i mean i'm even more detached now but back then
i was still like has he read it yet has he read
it yet but i know i'm patiently like okay don't
call him in a week don't call him in two weeks
but then i think i called him like maybe three
weeks later and he said oh no i haven't read it
yet but i'm gonna get to it i'm gonna get to it
and then uh the next call he called me and he
said i read your script and i didn't know howard
from adam right that was a really nice guy like
he's really cool he's really like unassuming
you wouldn't know that he has a bathtub award
or that he's been nominated for an emmy you
know that he uh produces these big cw campaign
commercials i mean you just wouldn't know it and
so that's what i liked about him like he's really
like just low-key and assuming unassuming and so
he just had an off-the-cuff chat yeah i liked your
script he said you know it's okay he says you
know why don't you come in we can talk and uh
he invited me down to the office and i came down
to the office and i met with him and we just i
think we kind of just hit it off right away again
he's just a very unassuming low-key kind of guy
and uh you know he talked about ava you know
the journey of making independent films and
why he was passionate about supporting younger
artists new emerging filmmakers anyhow he had uh
he was just committed to that i mean he's just you
know he was committed today he did it with ava and
so he uh took the film you know took the script
and then we started to work together at that point
in terms of developing and like i said it took
over a year to get it to where we needed it to
be and during that point i would just rewrite it
i would give it to him and he would give me notes
and rewrite it and give it to him give me notes
and so we went back and forth for you know a few
drafts until we got it to where we needed it to
be and you emailed him initially do you is that
right yeah i emailed him uh or did i call him i
think i called him i think i called i don't know
you know sometimes i write the emails but it's
like it depends because i don't want to catch
people off guard you know when you write when you
call them right away it's like oh hello you know
they have to adjust themselves and i don't want
them to play pretend and all that stuff so um
but i think in howard's case because brian
the guy i met set up the introduction
um i think i called him i think i called
him i may have emailed him i don't know
i don't know it could have been an email actually
and he gave me his number and he said let's talk
it may have been an email sure it could have been
because i like that soft intro sometimes it gives
people they can gather themselves on the other
end you know well he doesn't know if you're a
solar panel salesman yeah he didn't know you know
of course and you know how it took a big gamble
too because to see in my mind i'm thinking
i'm ready i can do a film i know i can right
but from the other person who's financing the film
who's going to produce it he didn't know because
it's not like i done i did yeah i did some shorts
and he saw the shorts but it's not like i had done
a feature before features a whole nother animal
we can talk about that it's like um a short film
is a short film to itself but a feature in
terms of shooting it we did ours in 17 days
the actors following first act drama second act
third act and then arc of characters and then um
uh just the stamina as a director to show up every
day with with a game plan it takes something you
know and everybody everybody and sometimes you can
fail on the job like you know what i mean like you
could be a first-time director and get all set but
you better have first a.d who's very clear about
laying out a schedule uh a dp who's done this
numerous times so they've got you sort of
um they're supporting you in making that first
feature and so that the margin of error for you
becomes less right does that make sense because
you're a first-time director but yet you've got
you know an a.d an experienced producer in howard
and you got a dp who can sort of steer the ship
but when you when you don't have that you know
and then you got a first-time director out there
anything can happen so you you don't know you know
you become an unproven talent until you've done it
you know and uh so i knew i could do it i
felt i was very confident about that i've
been on enough sets and my experience doing
the shorts and the documentary and i had
i had an acumen around film i
studied a lot of films i had uh
yeah but i mean the things surprised me on the
set too i mean it was like yeah it was it was
still it was still a challenging experience
you know like i was still figuring things out
you you know what i mean like i remember one day
i showed up on set and kiera kelly was our dp
kara kelly now shoots uh queen sugar uh uh black
woman dp uh really talented and so i remember one
morning we did a shot list top to bottom right and
so we knew exactly how we were going to approach
each scene the movie in itself you can kind of do
that with a 16-day shoot and you or you better do
that you better be very specific about what you're
going to cover because you don't have a lot of
like we're not we don't have a spielberg set where
we can play with or we're going to shoot this one
scene one day you know or david fincher yeah let's
just do this one scene one day you know like we
got to shoot like really four or five scenes
in a day and so um but i showed it one morning
and i said i got an idea for the shot right and
she looked at me she said yeah i said yeah why
don't we start here and put it on a dolly and then
move it up here as they get out of the car right
he said wow that's really cool i like that she
said but that's not on the shot list we didn't
talk about that i said i know i know but it's cool
because i got inspired right i got inspired that
night before i said i know it's a cool shot it's
gonna look really cool and uh she said yeah no
but we didn't talk about it and i said but she
said but you want to do it i see yeah she said
but it's gonna take a little time because we
gotta put the dolly blah blah blah blah i said
nah but let's go let's go for it and they started
to set up the track right and one dolly man and
what and he was one dollar grip and he was laying
the track and he was you know leveling the track
and then hadn't even put the dolly up there yet
and i looked at him i said damn this is 10 minutes
and he hadn't even laid that track yet and he's
still trying to level it and i'm like 15 minutes
and i said scrap it let's go back to the plan
let's go back she said you sure she's a really
professional dp and what i liked about it was
she's going to give me my vision right so she was
cooperative in that sense you know a lot of dp's
you know argumentative and whatnot i mean not all
of them but you know i've heard stories but she
was very like it's your vision let's do it um but
i saw how long it was taking to put that track up
and i said kill it kill it let's go back and she
said you sure i said yeah so that was an instance
where in terms of me growing as a director knowing
especially with this budget what you can do and
what you can't do right and we could not afford
whether time money or otherwise to lay a track
down and do a dolly and i didn't have a trained
crew like that you know like i didn't have i've
been on other sets where uh they have dolly grips
and two or three people working to dial it we
didn't have that you know we had like two people
in the dollar in the grip department two people in
the lighting department some days we spread out to
three but on bigger scenes but we didn't have
that so i was like you know what so i learned
my lesson i may have cost this 15 minutes but
if i had continued on that path to do that shot
i would probably cost us about 45 minutes really
because then now you have to allow for the shot
one time you have to allow for the dolly oh they
missed the dolly mark then you got to allow for
the pull focus oops he missed his mark so
everybody got allowed for a mistake right
and then the guy pushing it oh he made a mistake
so it's like you know it it increases the um
uh the take value or the ratios in terms of
shooting it too so i surrendered it but i say that
by way of a learning lesson you know i learned
by doing the first feature too and imagine if she
had fought you on it you might have spent a half
hour trying to prove your point oh yeah so it was
brilliant that she said okay oh yeah you sure okay
let's and then you got to see within 15 minutes
that it was gonna cost more time yeah exactly
exactly so you know sometimes it's just there's no
getting around doing a first feature like you have
to do it and like people think it's i don't know
if people think they can dial it in or it's easy
i don't i sometimes i get that impression when i
talk to filmmakers especially that somebody that
haven't done it before they think they can just
they're going to be great at it but you know it's
like anything else you know whether you do sound
or you deep they don't look at it like a dp like
a dp you know when you shoot something it's going
to take a minute to perfect your craft it's just
going to take a minute lighting you know camera
lenses it's a very technical thing but being a
good director can be that too right sometimes
people think you just step on set and just oh
boom let's make it happen but no you know the good
directors the really good ones they've worked at
it they worked at it so um i have an appreciation
for directing and i do a lot of studying on it
blocking you know coverage you know working with
actors i've taken classes you know in terms
of directing classes brad barnes does a great
uh director's working with actors class i've taken
that frederick huggles writing because i think all
directors should be able to write i mean it helps
it helps you to understand story arc where it's
going you don't become it's just you know yeah it
just helps you become a better story technician
so you know i i believe in the craft i believe in
knowing the craft i've worked with actors a lot
and so it becomes very helpful yeah having done
many short films when you actually started with
the feature did you think you were going to be as
calm under pressure when things you're having to
come up with not just a plan b but a plan c and
then you know that there's all this money riding
on and there's all this time you got to make your
day yeah did you realize how much pressure there
would be having to make these decisions on the
fly yeah it was gradual it was gradual because
um i heard somebody explain it to me like
this like you could be a producer right and
say somebody's driving you there's a driver
and he drives you to no no this is a better
example okay so you're going to school right
and so your mother's driving you every day
she's driving every day to school you're just
kind of sitting there you're on your phone you're
talking or you're on the email and you've done
this route to school like a million times right
and then one morning your mother says okay
you drive and all of a sudden you're like uh
which way am i going right so it can be like
that a little bit you know like i had i've
been even though i'd been on a million sets
and i had worked as a sound technician and um
you know i've added it's not you know but to be
in the seat of dr directing it's a whole different
conversation the decisions that are being put
on you the questions i mean you get a million
questions a day right and then having to just be
very clear about your shot and then being able
to walk away from a scene saying we got it or we
don't got it we need to stay longer right or how
okay i shot this i took more time than i needed
to i really going to screw myself up at the end
of the day so now i have to think about a wonder
and wow i can get make my day that way so i mean
it was it was it was very it was challenging i
mean it was it was challenging at times you know
i was getting that muscle up you know to become
yeah i was getting that muscle i think i think
i came with a lot of strong stuff like i work
with actors a lot and so that was sort of easy
for me you know um technically working with
the equipment was it was i had a handle on that
i think it was the scheduling and kind of knowing
how long things would take like the action
sequences i did like i did not know it was going
to take as long as it took and so when we did
the schedule and so i'm sitting there as the ads
doing the schedule and he's saying yeah this is
this is and i'm signing off on it you know and i'm
signing off on the basic basic i don't really have
the exp i mean i'm not i haven't done the action
right but i'm signing off on it basically yeah it
should take that long to take that long but it's
the difference between that and having experience
doing it right that's why you're going to do your
second feature your third feature you're like no
no no i need more time no no that's not going to
work oh yeah i can cut that yeah we can get that
in the early point and we're done you know like
we did a lot of car shots the hostess trey i mean
one day the guy set up the hostess straight and it
wasn't my fault and it wasn't um the ads fault but
the guy just took forever to set up the hostess
tray for the car mount shot right it's because
he didn't know what he was doing he just did not
know what he was doing and it took him a long time
or i shouldn't say he was green he wasn't an
experienced guy so that's the other thing when
you work with independent or lower budgeted films
sometimes you're not getting the cream of the crop
right so you're getting guys that you
know trying to break in trying to you know
you know for elevate themselves in their own
careers but this is where they are right now
so the guy just took forever and so i was like
wow this is killing us man this is killing us
and so i had a minute i had to just switch up and
say we can't do this we got to go to another shot
or he screwed because he didn't know what he was
doing or he just screwed us now we had to go from
i couldn't do the cross coverage i
wanted now i had to do one coverage right
from one side of the car and so now and i learned
this when we were doing this the actors the actors
already known this because they had played um
they had been on a lot of sets you know you got to
give credit to actors man i mean the really good
ones they do this a lot and they know what to do
so when they played the scene they played
to this camera so even though i'm side angle
they played this way right and so i covered the
camera covered their performance in a way where
they knew the blocking right in the car now the
minute i said to them i think we have time to go
to the other side they were like whoa oh we played
for this camera you switch if now if we'd known
you were going that way look we could have played
it like this she could have turned but we thought
it was going to be one angle you see i was like ah
got it got it so we just stuck with the one shot
yeah i learned that you know what i mean on the
set that day okay so actors you know they know
you know but i always like to inform my actors
anyway this is the blocking this is the shot
blah blah blah but the minute i said we're going
to switch and go another way they were like
but we played it this way for this camera it looks
beautiful for that camera but if they had known we
were going two cameras guess what they'd be
turning like this turning like that yeah so
yeah there's no there's no um there's no
getting around doing a first-time feature
and i don't think and hey listen you can do a
lot of preparation but until you're on that set
until you're there the first day um i mean it
still becomes a first time feature experience
yeah just be as prepared as you can be and
surround yourself with good people and we did that
you know and howard having done uh this a number
of times i mean sometimes i get to sit in the
morning i'm seeing howard moving to jenny i mean
he's a hands-on producer too so not as that and he
used to be an a.d so he was an a.d in canada for
a lot of years before he became a producer so uh
the last two days we lost our a.d because he was
sick i mean he just got i think he had some kind
of food poisoning or whatever not from the set but
you know he got sick and so howard had stepped in
and guess what both days we we managed to wrap
before schedule like an hour early both days and
he was so efficient and on time and it was just
like i was like howard how did that he say hey man
but he knows how to a.d you
know he knows how to run a set
so i was blessed to have him as a producer on my
first film can we talk about the time frame and
the conversation that you had with howard about
developing or redeveloping the script for skin in
the game because he saw it he said i like it but
yeah yeah so howard had liked it and he had uh
uh there was no commitment there was
no commitment that he was gonna make it
there was no i mean we were just doing the dance
if you will you know and at the time because
it was benefiting the script and because it was
becoming better i was like okay this this works
you know what i mean but i didn't know if he was
going to make it or not i didn't know at the end
of this journey so i was still sort of you know
still trying to find a way to do it independently
like if you will like i was still trying to raise
a hundred thousand dollars here i thought maybe we
could have done it for three hundred two hundred
thousand dollars so i was like okay well maybe
at one point i think we can do a fifty thousand
dollars so i was like because i was just you know
i was yeah i don't know if i was i'm
not gonna use one always word desperate
but i wanted to make a movie like i wanted to
make a movie right but you got to be careful with
that word desperation because that desperate
causes you to rush a script into production
being desperate causes you to uh oversee like
over overlook certain things like the script may
not mechanically work or maybe have problems but
she's like oh god i just got to make this movie
so desperate is not a place you want to be you
know you talked about being on set sometimes
and you just don't want to be that guy who's
or girl woman who's on set being desperate you
want to be calm about the whole thing right and
so i had peace of mind during the whole process
but i didn't know if he was going to make
it or not and so i was looking for other
at that time probably you know seeing how we could
do it for a hundred thousand dollars or whatnot
um and it was it was a year i mean you look
up but you know a year goes by kind of fast
like you're like uh wait a minute three months
have passed you know you do a rewrite two months
to pass you give him a script it takes him a
month to read it you know then he gives you back
he calls you there's notes then he travels he's
hey boom he's he's at a sundance film festival
you know so then that month is down and then he
comes back and then he has to gear up for this
commercial thing so it's like i'm working so
it doesn't feel like a year but a year goes
by right before before we make the movie yeah
and the script is constantly getting better and
it's constantly evolving and we're constantly in
communication and talking you know about you know
you know what it could look like and yeah so then
sending him revisions and then he gives you notes
yeah i was sending revisions he had had uh uh
mike now is uh is over there he's a co-producer
over there and mike would give us notes i would
go sometimes i'd walk in we'd sit down we'd talk
they'd both give me notes we could change this
whatever we think about this and it was never like
dictatorial you know they would just be making
like like suggestions you know i think it would
be better if we did this and blah blah blah
because howard in his company they really
i think they protect or they they respect the
vision of the filmmaker right so it wasn't like
they were trying to change my vision at all it
was just always about like how do we make this
a better house this can be a better house this
can be a better what if we add this what if we
take this away you know like uh the ending was
a big was a big thing for us you know because
sundance and usually independent film usually
like places like sunday like darker endings
right they like gritty endings and so you know we
played with the ending a lot you know but then i
think there was uh who told me this yeah one
of my survivor women told me don't make it uh
a dark ending she told me even though the reality
for most of these girls is they don't get out
right a lot of them truthfully either succumb to
drugs you know uh they get worn out and they uh
some of them die you know i mean you know
the lifespan of a prostitute is only like
seven years yeah and so you know or the od so it
becomes it's like a very grim experience and so
but she told me do not show the ending so in our
movie i don't want to give you any spoilers but
there was a point where the hair uh the lead girl
gets caught into the life and doesn't come back
but this person the survivor told me she said
don't do that because she says the pimps will
use it as a recruiting tool and they'll
use it to say look see she couldn't get out
you see see this movie this is the truth this
is your reality so don't even try and everybody
it really it meant something to me so i shared
that with howard and then too you know and uh i
think it impacted all of us you know in terms of
the way we shaped the the movie toward the end
yeah did anybody try to talk you out of making
the movie in that they thought maybe you can't
get distribution because of the subject
matter distributors might be scared of it
yeah well that's that that's where howard was
key but i remember one of our first meetings
and he repeated this a lot he said listen this can
movie after we finish it it can be a paperweight
it can uh it can be an exercise of futility
it can sit up there on the bookshelf there
it's just uh you know um you know
just it's like just collecting dust
right it may go nowhere right he was very real
i mean like i was like i mean you know i mean
i was like you know like because that's that was
my thinking right at all but he had again he's an
experienced producer and he's done this a number
of times and then we met again we were getting
ready to make the movie he said listen this can
either sit on the shelf it can be a paperweight
or it can be an exercise of utility like he said
that exact same thing and um do you still want to
do this you know and i said yeah you know and but
see he had been to the other side of the mountain
he had been the journey before so he knew right
so even now as we get skin in the game out there
to audiences and it's been a great journey it's
been a great journey right um but we didn't get
into sundance we didn't get into tribeca you know
we didn't get into toronto uh we didn't get into
south by southwest we didn't get into any of the
top tier festivals right so that was a whole year
because if you know anything about festivals they
want to premiere your film first the top tier ones
if they don't get access to your film first like
say if you premiered it chicago international film
festival and then sunday and say okay we want your
movie we want the exclusive rights to the premier
and you're like well we already premiered it son
at chicago they're like well we don't want it
so that happens a lot so you have to um gauge it
and we had to go a whole like almost cycle year
of trying to get into the big festivals then when
we didn't get into the big festivals then we could
back up and say okay we didn't get into all the
big ones right and why do you want the big ones
because the distributors are there because the
buyers are there because the national press is
there right the attention is there so you want to
hold out for those festivals but when you don't
get it then you say okay now what are the second
tier festivals and uh so then we were fortunate
i mean we were fortunate in the sense that we
premiered at urban world in new york in september
which is a great festival you know we had a great
premiere there then we went up to uh whistler film
festival in canada and then we ended with the pan
african film festival and we won best director
best first feature film right so yeah it was
uh it's been a journey but to your point about
how we're talking about the paperweight but
now we're in the process of distributing it
right and distributing it is almost as hard
as making it like when you ask yourself
what is the hardest part writing the script
making it or distributing it i'm almost like
well distributing it is hard as hell because now
you got to get it out there to people people have
to see it you want people to see it and so um yeah
it takes it's and we're an indie film so it's like
ch choo choo choo choo choo yes you can yes you
can choo choo choo choo choo you know so plus it's
not as sexy to be distributing it yeah when you're
on set oh yeah you're you're even though there's a
stressful moment and then you made another point
about the subject matter so so howard was also
very clear this is this is not a popular subject
matter or a lot of people don't want to see that
kind of thing it's in the shadows right and so
even my wife for instance never read the script
even when we finished the film she never saw
it and she was actually when i was writing the
scriptures like how can you write that how can
you you know i mean it created something for her
in terms of just the subject matter and we had two
little girls so it was and i understand it right
and so i knew just translated from that to what
howard was saying it's not gonna be an easy sell
and you know for whatever reason people are not
gonna just be it didn't matter how good the film
is you're just going to be drawn to the subject
but i would say i'm willing to roll the dice
in spite of all that he said let's roll the
dice knowing what he knew is a businessman
he said let's roll the dice yeah it seems
like you're attracted or you're willing to
explore dark subject matter and and know that a
lot of people may not want to see they may know
about young children working in mines and it's
horrible but i do i really want to spend years
why do you think you're willing to go there
well because as much as you talk about the
dark subject matter and the darkness of the uh why
do i go there i'm an optimist and so i like to see
the light in the darkness you know sometimes
i think the light is in the darkness right
and so i'm gonna go there because i'm still
fighting for the hope and the possibility
right so i'm never going to tell a story where
it's just dark right and then at the ending
it's it's like unconscionable and you know i'm
always gonna there's gonna be a spin on it right
or there's gonna be a um a take on it so in the
diamond mine thing you know we got the kids out
of the mines you know we funded them in soccer and
we put them in schools so that was like there was
there was something that came out of that right
and so with the girls it was important for me to
tell the subject matter but it was also important
to tell that one story of possibility and hope
you know the girl that made it the girl that
did get out and so we can cling on to that you
know so i'm not afraid of the darkness but
you know for me it there has to be that um
that thing where i'm not gonna just live in there
just you know wallow in it yeah there's got to be
some um some hope some possibility so i'm always
fighting for the possibility and the hope has
anyone just said make a romantic comedy why don't
you know it's just it's an easier sell or what
yeah and and if if your heart's not in it how do
you feel about that yeah yeah no i've i've gotten
that um you know just do a romantic comedy just do
a light uh drama um which i probably will do one
day but um that's not who i am you know it's just
not not who i am in terms of that uh yeah in terms
of developing material in terms of my interest
right now in terms of what i'm excited about
but i hope to you know i hope to lighten it
up do a romantic comedy one day do do comedy
but just right now it's this is just you know this
is where my interest is this is what what draws me
so is your sort of approach to filmmaking similar
to life where you just kind of tell it like it is
and has that worked for you or has it ever
rubbed people the wrong way it's interesting
that you should mention that i'm so glad you
mentioned that actually uh because there's two
school of thoughts and i've heard uh gina prince
life with the director of love and basketball and
uh disappearing acts she talks about
this as a writer and director she said um
you can tell it like it is right like you can
exactly replicate life and this this is what it
is and if it's bad it's bad if it's if it's uh
you know dark it's dark and just i'm just gonna
show you like it is and she says but she prefers
to tell a story that is how it could be opposed
to just what it is and i subscribe to that you
know i don't mind showing it like it is but i
also want it to be like this is how it could be
mm-hmm and you think that's from your parents
because they were willing to to help some of the
other kids and and you know they were always sort
of this foundation for you yeah i think i think
a lot of it goes back to my parents because um
i lived i mean i lived in a realm of possibility
you can do this my mother always said you can do
this and she always supported me and whatever
i did i wanted to be a filmmaker she's like
you can be a filmmaker if i wanted to be go to nyu
she said you can go to nyu so she's always been in
my corner even when sometimes she's like uh well i
wasn't a sound man you need did you join the union
you know you need to be in the union you know you
need the foundation you secured i was like oh mom
you know i need to i need to stay loose i need to
be you know i can't be like in the union because
that means i'm a sound man i can't be too much
like i can't be considered that and even though
i'm in the union now right but uh or i became in
the union at one point but i was like nah i need
to stay loose and so um but they've been they've
always created a level they've always supported me
in a way where i could create possibility and
so i think yeah it filters down into my work
where i don't just want to show what is
but i also want to show what's possible
was the first day on set for skin in the game more
emotional than any of the short films that you had
reported to or done on your own yeah i think
uh you talk about the first date but i i got
to tell you there was probably two periods where
i cried i just couldn't believe this was happening
i mean like that kind of cry like i was i was
very grateful of having had the experience i
had a moment you know usually when you're shooting
a film there's no moments to do anything but like
let's keep marching ahead let's keep marching
it and once you get that ball rolling it's like
you're rolling next day second day third you
know so it's like but there was there were two
days where i probably paused and i just some
tears came in my eyes because i was just so
overwhelmed with the fact that this was happening
and i was grateful and it was it was sort of
victorious for me in a way that all this
15-year journey was culminating into this
you know and then what happens to is you've
been told no so many times that you know
you get beat down by the no and so that when the
yes happens sometimes there's a disbelief like
is this really happening is this really
happening and so it took a moment to sink in
that this is really happening and i'm
really directing my first feature so yeah
wow yeah did did it get in your head at all like
mess with you a little bit or then once the train
was going you were just well you know the thing is
that's the thing about it once the train is moving
it's moving and you're the leader and um the day
the day or the actors or the shots that you choose
it it rises or falls with you so you just have
to embrace that and i i braced that pretty fast
like i just i didn't have too much time to sit
back and be like oh uh you know i had to get
into into director mode you know and that meant
efficiency that meant you know having the actors
believe in me and have confidence in me as
the directors and that meant coming prepared
and you know i like to work with my
actors you know so i like to you know
sit time to rehearse even though we had limited
rehearsal up time up up front of the film like
maybe one or two days which wasn't a great and i
didn't get a chance to rehearse with all of them
i always liked it before the scenes you know i
would go into the trailers and say let's talk
through this scene let's work it out you know
it's working out and i always because of the
the work i did with brad barnes who works at
the uh directing actors workshop he never let
the actors rehearse alone so i take that into my
practice too he said because what happens is and
i've seen it actors will end up creating
motivations and objectives for themselves
without you right as they work alone and
inevitably one actor may end up directing
the scene like one actor may take charge so
then that may create some division on set
where one actor feels you know like superior
than another so he wants to eliminate that
and he wants to eliminate the fact that
when you work when actors work up front
on the scene together they locked it so then when
they come to sit and it's locked and you look at
it and you're like oh no that's not it that's not
it you know so it may be good for them but it may
not serve you as a storyteller as a director for
the overall picture you know or maybe not even for
that particular scene so i don't like them to work
together beforehand they can run lines but that's
it but don't start sitting there talking about
okay i'm gonna do this i'm gonna do this and i'm
uh i'm gonna do that let the director
come in and do that and shape the scene
what are the biggest lessons making this film
is taught to you wow hindsight is 20 20. um
well you know it's always it's always difficult
to look back on your work and talk about what you
could have did or what you should have did uh
but there were some different choices i would
have probably made with the script looking back
on it now i'm going to get too specific about
that because i want people to enjoy the movie
and i don't want to talk about maybe if this
was five years and the movie was removed then we
could talk about it but now it's so fresh i want
people to go into the movie and be thinking oh
this that any other but there are probably some
different choices um i could have made script wise
um ano another big lesson is trust your gut yeah
trust your gut yeah no i yeah and i
and that just goes down to hiring crew
uh when you're all set making decisions around
shots you know because sometimes what happens
on the film set people you know everybody's there
to make the film right and everybody's there to uh
have a good experience in making it but
for some of us at the end of the day they
just want to go home right and also their
level of investment sometimes it's just like
you know they just if you say we're going
to rap at 12 they're like oh let's go home
you know what i mean and so you you may get one
shot in the scene and say let's rap at 12. so
just to really trust yourself and you got to hold
to your guns and sometimes that means being um
no we don't have it you know we got to we we need
to we got to keep working and we got to keep and
i did that a few times with the scene because i'm
not one to shoot a bad scene and so if the scene
is not working and i've done that i had to shut
the scene i had to shut this to set down one time
we were at dukko's house and um the dialogue
wasn't working i put the scene up and it was
not working and i could tell sometimes you can
tell if it's the dialogue or if it's the actors
delivery or it's the scene itself it's lacking
something right in terms of um a point of view but
the dialogue wasn't working it was just not
working because when we when steve had wrote
it and i worked with him on you know in terms of
the direction of the script it was it was slow
but then when we shot it it was an act it was it
was an action but dukko had held a gun up it moved
fast the scene was moving really fast so all the
words that he was saying and that she was saying
back it just didn't work right and so i had to
shut down the scene and i told everybody take five
take ten minutes you know just take ten minutes
and we're under the clock we're constantly under
the clock as we're shooting right and so you wanna
do these kind of things beforehand but we didn't
have a chance to rehearse this ahead of time so i
had to kind of rehearse it on set and then when we
played the scene i was like this isn't working
and the actors knew it wasn't working that's
that's the that's sort of the best part about it
too is that actors know it's not working right and
they're seeing if you know it's not working and so
if it's not working you got to fix it so i pulled
everybody off set we went into another room and i
started to rewrite the scene right then there okay
boom that works boom that works okay boom look
take that away run it again boom that doesn't
work okay say this okay boom let's put you here
all right you know and the actors have already
done their work focus intention what i want from
the scene the objective they've done that right
so but then it may be honing that objective more
right or it may mean in this case we gotta you
know we don't need you to say nothing just feel it
and it registers right and so we did that and then
when i put the scene up it's magic it was magic
i think the actors were proud of it i was proud
of it i mean and the crew was because the crew was
proud too because ultimately nobody wants to shoot
garbage you know i mean like they don't i mean
you can put people in front of the camera you can
put a director there but if you're shooting it
i've been on enough sets too where if it's just
bad it's like uh it's bad you know we don't want
to shoot that it doesn't do anything for anybody
so but you know i learned to you know i
learned to trust myself in those situations
i learned to trust myself and then do what
it do what it takes to to make the scene work